what's going on everybody welcome to
show my name is Tim Poole and I'm and
I'm Adam Krueger that's Adam
hello we're hanging out we also got
Lydia of Whiterun chillin hi dude the
news is getting scary it is serious
again scary there was there was a period
where kind of felt like things were
things were chilling out yeah I was
feeling better seemed like things might
get back to normal Trump's talking about
getting things back up and going by
Easter
yeah now we're growling but now we're
then then was it the Surgeon General
said not it's gonna get real bad and
then and then someone posted something I
saw this I don't know where I saw this
they said April 1st
tick tock what's going on with that rent
is due
oh no one pays rent Yeah right nobody's
worked for the past what week and a half
two weeks two weeks most people can't
handle a four hundred dollar bill let
alone two weeks of not working at all
and right now the funny the the the
funny story that everyone's talking
about is that Cheesecake Factory is not
gonna pay its rent and it's like it's
not necessarily funny haha it's funny
like people are laughing like oh no
Cheesecake Factory they're joining the
socialist revolution or something that's
scary as a major food chain I honestly
kind of expected them to die off already
but they're long ago they're always
packed it's like a big mall restaurant I
had no idea oh yeah the last time I was
in there was with you and me no it was
kind of it was a weekend it was packed
but it was a weekend so it's not even
about whether we want to speculate as to
the economic health of the Cheesecake
Factory the franchise another matter
remains there no dude April rent April
1st is days away and many people have
just skipped a paycheck or more yeah and
they're gonna be I'm gonna yeah we're
not gonna pay it or they can't get
evicted right now right I mean I don't
know but but but this is gonna ripple
man cuz check it out yeah that means all
of these landlords who are waiting for
that money to come in to pay their bills
right boom that's when it hits it's
gonna ripple out like a man like a gong
slam bomb
you know landlords then they have no
money can't pay the maintenance people
here we go yeah and that's just the
first thing on the list yeah man man
this is getting scary
yeah well before we get going I don't
know if you guys can see my shirt we get
the mic out of the way check that out
check out my nice shirt for those are
let anybody recognize this shirt Adam is
wearing a shirt with my beanie on it I
am wearing his beanie on my shirt this
came in the mail today we got it's the
wrong colors but it's pretty sweet thank
you it's okay you know this needs to be
darker but I think it's great you know
it's funny it actually matches my hat my
colored beanie diffusion it's a fusion
of our beanies all right all right
anyway yeah even though the world is
ending we all have a good laugh get your
beanie shirt and then we and then we
have a nervous laugh because it's
getting scary out there man but hey
before we get started the first story
which is one of the scariest things I
have ever heard yeah this hospitals are
basically saying you die you die young
you die and we're not gonna save you
this is from the Washington Post
hospitals considered universal do not
resuscitate order for coronavirus
patients that basically means if you are
brought to the hospital with corona
virus and you start going into it
they're gonna be like yeah it's nice
knowing you buddy
I mean they'll put you on a ventilator
though right is that the case or is it
after no I don't know after that and
then it doesn't work then it's like
maybe nothing else we can do maybe I
would think that they would draw the
line at trying to resuscitate our yes
doing compressions and stuff right right
I see they're talking about all hands
responses okay so you're on a ventilator
you start spazzing out they're gonna be
like dude you know they're I was reading
some of these stories and they said that
there were people who were on
ventilators and you can see them slowly
turning blue
really oxygen in their lungs on maximum
pressure yeah because the fluid buildup
was so intense that even with pure
oxygen and they have the Machine blowing
air in and pulling out yeah Shh at max
your all your lungs are always inflated
you're not breathing you're just in
yours knocked out with a tube down your
throat yeah and
or slowly turning blue because they were
getting no oxygen so they're basically
like you know what we can't do anything
about it I mean like how do you do
anything about it other than like
operating and taking out the fluid or
scraping the sides of the lungs can you
even do that
no because it's a fine network of really
really tiny little capillary balloons
and what's what I was reading is they
said that when they fill with fluid they
and then they put when they when they
put people on the ventilators at max
pressure yeah it starts breaking up a
little were they called like alveoli or
something
yeah whatever they start bursting and
then they become completely useless die
so the ventilators are actually having a
negative effect well you're dead without
it but it slowly rips your lungs apart
good people don't get it man this isn't
listen listen listen they're saying the
hospitalization rate is 20 percent right
okay like you realize that means if we
don't have hospitals the mortality rates
like 20 percent yeah that's true if
somebody needs to be in a hospital
because they're there they're collapsing
it's not that's that's a bit of an
exaggeration it's not 20 percent because
some people need me in hospitals just
for observation because they're getting
bad yeah but if we're if it's even 10
percent of people because uh Governor
Cuomo said 15 percent New York has right
now according to Cuomo ten thousand six
hundred beds available ICU beds okay
that means they can handle based on
their own numbers seventy thousand
people in New York City getting sick
eight million people live in New York
City alone just a city and this is
spreading I thought it was nine million
it's probably it's probably I mean look
pretty sure yeah but when you when you
combine the the suburbs places like New
Rochelle or like what else you got you
got WestJet Westchester no no what's
what's north of New York on the on the
on the Western of Manhattan I don't know
whatever it's called Yonkers yeah
there's Yonkers there's isn't
Westchester whatever the point is it
goes look like thirteen million so
that's why everyone's freaking out yeah
because people don't realize the
mortality rates down because people are
working overtime in hospitals yeah so
once we reach maximum like like with
full capacity basically it's like then
the deaths are just gonna really start
going up yep because right now we're
like
handling it as best we can with the load
that we can take care of yeah man well
so we're at this point now the
Washington Post is reporting it but
guess what this story that we're seeing
about the Washington Post it's it's been
repeated in by LP as in Spain and in
Italy and that they're getting to the
point where it's it's it's it's in
different forms but it's basically
deciding that you must die now yeah that
I'm sorry it's your time and the scary
thing is it's this is the most extreme
I've ever seen it where where they're
saying Universal DNR so like in Italy in
Spain they're basically saying perhaps
we just let the old people die and
prioritize the young yeah there's
they're not even saying that there's
right here the same thing in there
everybody anyone everybody anyone who
reason it up well that's and that's the
other thing too we got a bunch of
stories here about young people who are
dead 21 year old 25 year old 22 year old
seventeen year old seventeen year old so
you were saying there was an infant
there's a two month old right now on
life-support and there's a newborn in
isolation and it's because they have
coronavirus and it's like they were
they've been reporting as far as I
remember that it doesn't affect kids
doesn't hit kids at all no no dude the
media is full of it they're probably
full of it right now I had no idea
what's going on I have no husband for
like from end of January till the mid
mid February they were all the media was
going not saying and a flus worse yeah
and now a bunch of people are saying
that and they're going those dumb
conspiracy theorists bro they were
reading your news outlet The Washington
Post on what was it February 4th get a
grip America the flu is way worse where
we at now
a month later mm-hmm we will not try and
save your life I'm sorry
Thanks Washington Post that's on you you
know look I I was critical of the
president for having a doubt to having
downplayed the response but now the
media is trying to act like they're they
were right as well know everybody got
this one wrong yeah not everybody Tucker
was right Tucker Carlson Fox News was on
his a real early February 3rd I think
but but there were a lot of people who
were on this early and it wasn't the
media they were the ones who are dancing
around talking about how there's a meme
going around it's not really a meme but
it's this graphic of all of these
different news news articles it's
ridiculous like 25 30 or maybe maybe
even like
wirdy news articles where it's like the
flu was worse the flu was worse ignore
this Trump is exaggerating he's a bigot
and all this crazy stuff you know where
they downplayed it and this is where we
this is where we get to be right now so
this article is crazy yeah man well
let's uh let's let's let's read let's
read but real quick before we do if you
guys want to get into super chat and
have your questions answered by us we
will jump over and make sure you
subscribe if you want to get more videos
but let's let's read from Washington
Post they say hospitals in the
frontlines of the pandemic are engaged
in a heated private debate over a
calculation few have encountered in
their lifetimes how to weigh the quote
save at all costs approach to
resuscitating a dying patient against
the real danger of exposing doctors and
nurses to the contagion of coronavirus
the conversations are driven by the
realization at the risk to staff amid
dwindling stores of protective equipment
protective equipment such as masks gowns
and gloves may be too great to justify
the conventional response when a patient
codes and their heart or breathing stops
Northwestern Memorial Hospital in
Chicago has been discussing a universal
do not resuscitate policy for infected
patients regardless of the wishes of the
patient or their family members a
wrenching decision to prioritize the
lives of the many over the one I want
you to imagine something right now I
want you to imagine that's you inside a
hospital and that's your mom on a
breathing on a breathing tube and all of
a sudden start hearing beeping going off
and you start screaming help her please
and the doctor holds you back and says
no they're the people who downplayed
this stuff the people who joked and
laughed about it the people who think
it's not happening it's like I'll tell
you what man when when it when it
finally comes to you this is worse than
you know the grasshopper in the ant the
story where the grass out you know the
story yeah I talked about this when it
came to supplies like you know when the
store shelves get get you know shredded
you know you're gonna be you're gonna
come knocking this is way worse it's
gonna be you on your knees begging
please save my mom saved my dad save my
friend save my spouse whatever yeah and
it's not it and we could have seen this
coming
check this out in Italy the
extraordinary decision facing Italian
doctors there are now simply too many
patients for each one of them to receive
adequate care a lot of people think it's
not happening yeah they
reach critical mass over there in Italy
so now it's like getting to that point
and that was that was two weeks ago two
weeks ago so they're saying now that
Italy's getting past two weeks they had
to make these choices yep
so check it out I'm seeing a lot of
people say things like I don't know
anybody who has this right well good for
ya what does that mean right that's some
so not why YouTube right there it's like
dude have you have you have you watched
any of these videos hey man it's there
there was a 22 year old kid there's a
let me just show you some stuff man and
I want to come back to this though 21
year old woman with no underlying health
conditions dies of coronavirus and what
what do people think that like all of
these different cover meant sand people
who hate each other are working on the
secret plot like Trump and the Democrats
are working together to trick people
like that's ridiculous man do you think
she was a smoker
I don't know because I hear that if
you're a smoker it's significantly worse
so I'm hearing all these younger people
are dying and it's like were they
smokers because I mean I used to be a
smoker and I haven't quit smoking
six years ago so it's been a long time
since I've had a cigarette but I hear
it's really bad for your lungs in
general totally let alone a lung disease
listen we just watched some videos
before we went live and I can't I can't
confirm them so that's why I'm not gonna
pull them up but I I believe they're
more likely than not real of things
going down in China to this day
China's lying men definitely there's a
video going viral of like a bunch of
different clips of China having like the
entire highway is full of like 12 major
trucks sprang disinfectant yeah out of
these huge like there's and looking
things there's people there's like easy
what one clip is a person just like
laying on a bench and a bunch of got a
couple guys in hazmat suits come and
just like start taking the bodies
there's videos where someone's driving
on the street and there's bodies on the
sidewalk everywhere I kind of feel like
I've you know it's it's crazy because
that right now it feels like the media
especially Trump they're desperately
trying to keep everybody keep keep the
morale up yeah
Trump is saying we're gonna get back you
know the economy's gonna kick back into
gear on Easter
that's my goal right now he's like will
confer with the health experts and we'll
see what's going on doctor foul he said
we'll be flexible I think Trump is doing
that because he wants to give people
some certainty right now yeah so that
you know they're gonna be a lot of
people who think okay I'm gonna invest
in the market let's get the economy
working again because it sounds like we
may have an opportunity to make some
money here if we could you know get
going in Easter yeah I'm willing to bet
once we get to Easter the doctors and
Trump are gonna say we're really close
we did an assessment we think we need
one more week and then a week's gonna go
by and they're gonna say everything's
going great the markets can be rallying
now because we have some certainty one
more week one more week one more week
one more months later or something
happens and I think it just you know
here's the big here's the big challenge
hospitals need money hospital these
hospitals need resources and we can't if
the economy collapses yeah people die
and the hospitals are only gonna be able
to run for so long yep and what happens
when healthcare workers on the front
line start deserting or the electric
companies like their employees can't
make it back to work out because some of
them are dying and the electrode here
electricity goes out you know then
things are really screwed man it feels
like we are dangerously close to the
precipice on this really getting scarier
and scarier every but well but here's
the thing man the past week it kind of
felt like things were getting back to
normal almost not entirely but it felt
like it got really scary and then start
to get a little less scary like the
store had pet milk again well it looks
like it looks like the graph because if
you look at the graph from China goes up
and then it kind of teeters off for a
while and then spikes again yeah it felt
it feels like we're in we were in that
little stage where we're like wait is it
is it under control is it is it what's
going on and then now it's like oh wow
it's way worse than we thought it
actually gets a little bit scarier so
take a look at this story Spanish
doctors prepare to make difficult
decisions if intensive care units reach
capacity officials admit the worst is
yet to come as Spain exceeds 1,000
deaths in field hospital start going up
across the country this is from the 20th
now over back at the original story it's
not just about this one hospitals
Universal DNR it's that other hospitals
across the country have started deciding
to prioritize Huli
and who guys it's no longer that if
you're in the hospital we'll try and
save you now it's like look man we only
got so many beds yeah
here let's free a little bit more
officials at George Washington
University Hospital in the district say
they had a similar conversations but for
now we'll continue to resuscitate kovat
19 patients using modified procedures
such as putting plastic sheeting over
the patient to create a barrier the
University of Washington Medical Center
in Seattle one of the country's major
hotspots for infections is dealing with
the problem by severely limiting the
number of responders to a contagious
patient in cardiac or respiratory arrest
several large hospital systems atrium
health in the Carolinas Geisinger in
Pennsylvania and regional Kaiser
Permanente Networks are looking at
guidelines that would allow doctors to
override the wishes of the coronavirus
patient or family members on a
case-by-case basis due to the risk to
doctors and nurses or a shortage of
protective equipment say ethicists and
doctors involved in those conversations
but they would stop short of imposing a
do not resuscitate order on every
coronavirus patient the companies
declined to comment I want you to think
what that means they stopped short of
imposing it on every patient that means
they're literally gonna be deciding you
know what we are not going to save that
person yeah so now I want you to imagine
that scenario said again you're in the
hospital it's your mom and she's got a
ventilator and all of a sudden beep
beeping panic across the room is a guy
beeping and panic and the doctors run in
and there's a doctor in the hallway and
he says not her him and you say what
about my mom and he says we will not
save her no back up back up and then a
cop comes in and drags you out and you
watch your mom dies they drag you away
maybe it's a little extreme yes these
conversations scare me I have a vivid
imagination I mean yeah little bit now
now if you will the doctor gets
coronavirus because he's trying to and
then the entire staff gets it yeah and
then all of a sudden there's no more
staff or actually something I think is
worse it's you know I've read these
stories about doctors who have gotten
sick okay and a couple of lost their
lives in North North Jersey there was
this guy he was like his whole life he
was like cept in his lay
70s and he contracted it trying to save
people and died and and to me that's
like it's a very honourable way to go
you know it said it's sad to hear it but
what's scary to me is the dishonorable
way to go when doctors start saying I'm
not getting this man I've seen what it
does and they bailout nurses start
saying for what for why watching people
die every day getting paid nothing
working 14-hour days and your families
without toilet paper I know that sounds
like kind of funny but I mean like your
family has lack of resources you can't
pay your rent
you're not making nearly enough and
you're like I have to go yeah we need to
get out of the city this is
unsustainable then it all breaks the dam
the dam breaks thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune in to this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you